la normandie hérité du siècle dernier la
voici
divisée en deux depuis 1956 sur décision
politique les régions administratives
sont créés quarante ans plus tard leurs
concepteurs serge antoine déclare si
c'était à refaire je ne ferai qu'une
seule normande au 21ème siècle
elle sera réunifiée avant la normandie
du nouveau millénaire
retour sur plus de 2000 ans d'histoire
au 1er siècle avant jésus-christ la
normandie n'existe pas encore moins les
normands plusieurs irréductibles tribus
gauloises peuple de territoire une fois
la gaule conquise par jules césar de
ville prédomine
rothau magus aujourd'hui roi et novillo
magus lisieux les principales voies
romaines parts de ces deux cités après
les romains à l'antiquité les vikings
n'ont moyen-âge
les scandinaves aubert plusieurs raids
dès l'an 800 et menace paris en 911 le
roi de france charles iii dit le simple
signe le traité de saint clair sur epte
avec rôle au chef des vikings
il devient son vassal la terre concédé
s'appellera normandie pour north
semaines les hommes du nord
en un siècle et demi après plusieurs
conquêtes et addictions les frontières
du duché de normandie s'agrandissent
pour ressembler à celle que nous
connaissons actuellement
rouen en est la capitale vers l'an mille
cinquante guillaume le conquérant fait
deux camps simple bourgade une ville
majeure objectif asseoir son pouvoir sur
l'ouest du duché face aux barons
rebelles du bessin du cotentin
reste bien sûr la capitale officielle
mais depuis les origines ce qu'on nous
appelons aujourd'hui la basse normandie
il a échappé en quelque sorte au
contrôle des comptes droit en
s'installant à quand un centre de
pouvoir fort il va pouvoir enfin
contrôler toute la base d'hormones
aujourd'hui encore les bas-normands
n'accepte pas toujours la tutelle des
haut-normands quand elle s'exerce en
la normandie est rattachée au domaine
royal à partir de cette époque rond se
tournent de plus en plus vers paris elle
est le canal par lequel s'approvisionne
paris donc entre par rouen le sel qui
vient guérande qui viennent au portugal
et qui approvisionne toute la région
parisienne et le vin la laine le coton
aussi sur le plan économique
administratif rejoint s'impose compte de
ses faces pas pour autant en pleine
guerre de son temps entre français et
anglais
l'université y est implantée en 1432
rouen et la capitale politique et
administrative des anglais il semble
donc par compensation d'une certaine
manière qu'en été choisi pour en être la
capitale culturelle
les rouennais vont ils pour autant
étudie à caen
les étudiants de rouen vont à paris 1
voire même pour le droit puisqu'il n'y a
pas de droit civil à paris vont à
orléans mais ne viennent pas quant à la
révolution française
rouen regarde toujours vers paris et
adhère aux thèses révolutionnaires de
robespierre
même si les deux villes ne choisissent
pas le même camp politique
le légendaire comportement normand lui
ne change pas quand on dit que le
normand s'est peut-être bas qu'oui ptêt
ben qu'non
on en fait un défaut c'est en fait une
qualité
ça veut dire que le normand ne
s'enflamme pas vers telle ou telle
direction et réfléchit d'abord notre
tempérament nous unit paraît-il comme
nos racines ancestrales pour célébrer
nos origines scandinaves
un festival existe depuis 1992 les
boréales se l'imagerie vikings les
fondateurs du du festival avait avait à
l'esprit mais nous ont souhaité que cet
héritage soit vraiment contemporain soit
vraiment moderne et soit un héritage
palpable tous les jours parce que il ya
une espèce de présent scandinave un peu
immatériel dans cette dans cette ville à
caen en 2016 année de la réunification
les boréales devrait gagner tout le ciel
de normandie de rouen à cherbourg